when it's hunting for food you can hear
the pie coming from a long way off these
days the largest freshwater fish in the
Amazon River has become rare this is
exactly what shown here in the amelia
conservation area the fisherman was only
showing off this catch but in its
struggle to escape it suffered a heart
attack here in the heart of the
conservation zone there's a meeting
between representatives from regional
authorities scientists and
environmentalists from the German
society for international cooperation or
GI Z a couple up with our goal is to
make I to fishing legal again to make it
completely aboveboard that way locals
can adhere to a fishing plan and fish
sustainably debonding theater goals and
nine two fishermen count stocks by
listening after sunrise they count them
when they surface to breathe these
canoes have been on the water since
three in the morning Milagro selita's
kiddos from GI z is part of the team is
my nephew jose who had como it is called
nothing time it's amazing to see how
well the fishermen know the local marine
life they can recognize a breed just by
the way it sounds a conocer y como oyes
colossal wreck ok it's wonderful to see
how familiar they are with their
environment protecting it is in their
DNA thank you me that and that makes me
optimistic that they'll succeed how can
we just say that's how to eat
picha is considered a delicacy in Peru
contributing to the problem of
overfishing the Peruvian state is
therefore investing in peach a farming
and has given it protected status it's
now illegal to catch picha that are less
than 1 meter 60 in length fishing is not
allowed in the amelia conservation area
but indigenous fishermen are exempt from
the ban if they stick to sustainable
fishing rules they will soon be allowed
to fish pie Charley gallay until then
they have no choice but to let them slip
through their nets